كانت لتكون زياره عاديه اخرى لوفد
دبلوماسي من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي للمسجد
الاقصى لكن ليس بهذا التوقيت ولا بما احيط
بها من ضغوط مارسها الجانب الاسرائيلي
لتنسيق الزياره معه وليس مع الاوقاف
الاسلاميه
رفض الوفد ذلك باعتباره تغييرا للوضع
القانوني والتاريخي القائم في المسجد وهو
تماما ما اراد ان يتجنبه لم يدلي الوفد
باي تصريحات فزيارته تحدثت بنفسها عن
اهدافها
فيها
رساله الدعم واسناد لدائره الاوقاف
الاسلاميه وايضا دعم لو وصايه جلاله الملك
على المقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه في
مدينه القدس نحن في دائره الاوقاف شرحنا
لهم اوضاعنا في المسجد مع ما نوعانيه من
تعطيل اعمالنا من عرق اعمال للاوقاف
زياره بعد يوم واحد على عرقله شرطه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي دخول السفير الاردني
للمسجد الاقصى بذريعه عدم التنسيق المسبق
وكذلك بعد الاقتحام الاستفزازي لوزير
الامن القومي تمر بني كبير للمسجد بدايته
هذا العام
ما يحصل الان هو محاوله ترجمه فرض السياده
الاسرائيليه الكامله على المسجد الاقصى
المبارك الى واقع بعد زياره من غفير اللي
تمت ما بعد اعلان حكومه نتنياهو وما حصل
بالامس من منع السفير الاردني هي محاوله
لتقليص الدور الاردني على حساب همم
الوصايا الاردنيه اللي يجب ان نحترم
بالمسجد الاقصى المبارك
عبرت جهات دوليه عده عن خشيتها من ان يقود
تصعيد الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده الى
انفجار الموقف وبدات تلوح خطوات خجلا
لمواجهه ذلك اذ طلب وفد من مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي عدم الالتقاء باي من وزراء
التيار الصهيوني الديني او اعضاءه كما
يجري مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جيكسوليفان مباحثات مع مسؤولين اسرائيليين
ويتوقع ان يطلب خلالها عدم اتخاذ اي خطوه
قد تفجر الاوضاع لكن في المقابل يخشى
الفلسطينيون ان تحول الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ما يصنف انتهاكات الى جزء مما يسمى الوضع
القانوني القائم
يول الفلسطينيون اهميه بالغه لهذه الزياره
من حيث رسالتها وتوقيتها لكنهم يشددون
ايضا على ضروره تحرك الدول العربيه
والمجتمع الدولي وترجمه المواقف الى افعال
في مواجهه انتهاكات الاحتلال المستمره
للمقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه على حد سواء
نجوى سمري الجزيره القدس المحتله